Jason how hard is it for independent
filmmakers to get their movies on iTunes
Netflix Amazon well when you talk about
how difficult it is to actually get on
the platform it varies depending on
which platform you're approaching so for
iTunes you have to go through in many
cases you have to go through well I
should say for iTunes is in all cases
you have to go through an iTunes
approved aggregator or sub aggregator
that works with the aggregator and I'm
trying not to make this overly
complicated and often times that
aggregator if they're not an encoding
house they work with an iTunes approved
encoding house so there's two points to
it there's the aggregator and then
there's the encoding house the encoding
house is probably the more cumbersome in
terms of time and and things that have
to happen you have to get a pristine
file that can be delivered to iTunes and
past the internal iTunes QC so prior to
being delivered to iTunes the encoding
house will take you through a very
rigorous quality-control process on the
encoding house aside hitting all of the
little checklist to say doesn't conform
to this specification does it hit this
this this and this and if you hit if you
if you get any hiccups during the
encoding process then what oftentimes
happens is your movies reviewed to see
whether or not these hiccups can be
repaired in-house and if they can be
repaired in-house then it goes into
queue for a repair and it gets repaired
in-house eventually gets delivered to
iTunes and then when it's delivered to
iTunes itunes then conducts its own QC
process to make sure that it matches
specifications and if you can pass all
of those crazy check marks and get then
your movie will go live in iTunes right
and that could be a long process
especially for independent filmmakers
where there's there's hiccups with their
movie examples of that would be frame
rates are out of whack ghosting macro
blocking and I'm just naming a few
there's a whole list of different things
so that's itunes amazon's a little bit
easier to access amazon just
go through Amazon's create space Hulu
requires that in addition to matching
and conforming to all the QC things that
I mentioned earlier you have to make a
pitch to them and they have to accept
your movie and it's the same with
Netflix I would suggest you know as a
general release strategy utilize
transactional platforms first these are
platforms where somebody has to pay
money to actually see the movie before
you go into a subscription platform or
an advertised supported platform like
Hulu I've heard some people saying well
you can circumvent some of these
aggregators by building an app and I
don't know much about it can you tell me
yeah and again this this was never a
route that I took so I loose lis know
this but you can circumvent some of the
aggregators by building an app that
showcases your movies and I know there's
a company out there that does that but I
think I'd be doing us all a disservice
if I try to dive into that too much
because it just hasn't been you know
previous to my position at show I work
for an aggregator so I got to know how
to actually deliver movies into the
movie marketplace I don't know much
about the app marketplace and back in
the old days when blockbuster went oh go
straight to the shelves at blockbuster
do you remember some of the stories that
you would hear from I know that was a
while back but in terms of has it gotten
much harder or easier with the whole VOD
platform versus in-store yeah well I
think I think getting a movie in any
stores and on a physical shelf space now
I think a lot of those relationships
have deteriorated in terms of DVD sales
you still have red box and that's
something that a lot of filmmakers
pursue it's never been my interest
because my specialty and I think I'm
trying to ride the horse in the
direction it's going and I think
everything's VOD and audience engagement
online so that's really where my where I
spend most of my time there still is
opportunity on a degree for red box and
and to some degree Netflix for DVDs but
it's just it's just not a focus do you
think eventually the filmmakers should
not
make DVDs is one of their Kickstarter
IndieGoGo perks I think filmmakers
should always make DVDs up until the
point that DVDs are obsolete because
there are some movies out there where
you know maybe it appeals to an older
demographic and they still use DVDs the
way that we would recommend doing it a
chill is you still make the DVDs but
sell them as an exclusive merchandise
bundle so it's now on the autograph DVD
and instead of charging $10 now you
charge $40 because it's an autographed
exclusive DVD and there's only 40 of
them in the entire world that does a lot
of things it helps you improve your
profit margins helps you save time going
to the post office and it helps you find
out whether or not people that are into
your movie are also into DVDs and then
helps you strategize later
you